[Music]
esports is
no stranger to cringe
[Music]
from terrible handshakes to weird
entrances to god-awful trash talk
we've seen and gritted our teeth through
it all
but there is one moment one awkward
almost
unwatchable moment that we always come
back to
i think this guy talks a lot and it's
about time
for him to learn some respect it's a
legendary train wreck from half a decade
ago that literally produced
celebrated art and resulted in one of
competitive gaming's most
agonizing and humbling humiliations
chillin you have anything you want to
say to the people
this is probably the cringiest moment in
esports history and you have no idea how
bad it's going to get
how can i get off this stage as fast as
possible
all right let's turn back the clock a
little bit this is kashan chillin
khan otherwise known as chillin dude for
years he was one of the best
super smash brothers melee players in
the world very convincingly like zach
and jillian dude
two in a row from chillin chillin played
in what's sometimes referred to as
the golden age of competitive melee back
when the prize pools were minuscule and
there was nothing to win but glory
to really just [ __ ] on your opponent
while you're whipping their ass in the
game
it's it's really good it's a lot of fun
he was one of the first players to push
fox's limits and
despite not quite being on the level of
some of his peers
he was a likable genuinely adored and
respected figure in the scene
but as the years went on chillin
couldn't exactly keep
up with the competition i don't know
it's looking really
dramatic for chilling dude ah there it
is
just let's dash yeah even chilling kind
of greasy yeah that was pretty solid
and he's not punishing he's not
punishing a great effort by chill dude
right there but
mango was just able to clutch it out man
[Applause]
he was like i'm gonna you know just in
case you wanted to put this in the
highlights video
look by no means was chillin terrible he
just wasn't one of the game's elite
anymore
the golden age had passed and melee was
now being dominated by armada
mango hungrybox mew2king and yes
a guy who called himself dr pp they
became known as the
five gods and no one could stop them
well no one except for a certain swedish
super villain
the crowds for hungrybox oh that's it
leopard jumps out of his chair
hungrybox and losers bracket leffen was
a new breed of smasher
he was young arrogant and loved to talk
[ __ ]
i'm not i'm not happy until every aspect
of godhood is
like torn away and there's only one god
and that's me
but unfortunately for his opponents the
godslayer actually had the skills to
back it all up
they're both so stressed and they're up
smash and he wins
and he won leffen has finally beaten
armada he gets the assessor
takes it now it was around this time
that melee was experiencing
a renaissance the game triumphantly
returned to evo
the five gods and god slayer storyline
continued to evolve
and a documentary called the smash
brothers had brought a wave of new fans
into the scene just a few years earlier
the dock was also helping some of
melee's legendary names get
serious sponsorships team curse signed
chilean and ken
to revere names from melee's early years
to their roster and when the org merged
with team liquid
chilin was suddenly playing for one of
the biggest esports teams in the world
and leffen wasn't exactly happy about
that
it wasn't long before the trash talk
began flying all across twitter
with leffen publicly criticizing curse
and liquid's decisions to sign
has-beens like chilean dude which
chillin obviously didn't appreciate
in the slightest now despite the fact
that they had both tied for ninth at the
previous evo
leffen wanted to make it clear that they
were worlds apart as players
and he'd have his chance to prove it
after the two agreed to a first to five
money match at apex 2015 but to raise
the stakes they were also playing for
exclusive rights to use fox's default
colors in tournament
for the rest of time and to say that
leffen was confident heading into the
bout
would be an understatement i don't need
to say anything everyone knows what
i'm going to say and it's going to be
5-0
that that's how it's gonna be but
instead of just exchanging
bars and twitter threads chillin took
things a step further he wanted to give
leffen a lesson in how to
truly talk [ __ ] on the internet i'm not
lawful make this [ __ ] stop talking
you're not one of the gods who wanted
the god
awful we all got killed when looking at
your fox [ __ ] stick to smash 4 and
losing by 4 stops
yeah he really did that
p.s left i ain't done yet i'm the
underdog so place your
bets whoever wanna see left and looking
dumb
throw your money on the line cause i'm
making some chill and dude released a
diss track
called respect your elders which is
maybe the most boomer ass thing you
could name your rap
it's like naming your diss track get off
my lawn
or early bird special it sucks
and yet some people were kind of into it
i don't know if you've ever
actually looked into this guy's lyrics
as rhyme schemes as flows
because he's actually not that bad
despite chilean's deeply cringed bars
the smash community loved to respect
your elders whether it was out of
genuine affection or an ironic
appreciation for his lyrics
people were on board so why do they love
this song so much
well we had to bring in an expert to
tell us that respect your elders isn't a
train wreck
it's actually art meet omega sparks
he's part of the nerd core rap group
game breaks
and even founded his own battle rap
league in north carolina
a great battle song
is doing uh multiple things it's
basically
setting the stage pulling from real life
events
you know even if it's just from the
perspective of the person that's
battling and
they're not hitting on you know every
story note
uh in in the background from his
perspective he's telling his story
and he's hitting with punchlines
poignant it was it was his own point
chillin didn't just stumble into writing
the greatest diss track in smash history
and according to sparks what makes it a
masterpiece is that it came
straight from the heart you can tell in
his voice you can tell in the recording
as well
like he had a a very confident flow
about him
basically like i got you know and
telling everybody like you know place
your bets
he was very confident in in his vocal
recording
so he did he did a great job i think he
did everything he was intended
intending to do with the with the diss
track he definitely dissed him
so it turns out that respect your elders
is fire actually
lyrical audible gold a soul-crushing
diss track
that leffen never should have recovered
from the people wanted leffen to respond
but
he didn't give them a track of his own
instead he showed up at apex 2015's
salty suite intent on making chilean
dude eat his
own words all right let's just play i
can bother this fraud and let's
move on all right all i gotta say is
evidence
dot zip evidence stop this is looking
more like a body bag.zip right now
zip them up destruction of tv three
you slip them up laughing is laughing
he's like is this man really trying to
fight me right now
who was gonna commit first who was gonna
mispay something oh
wow and chilling right now is a member
of the salvation army
giving away that stock oh it's a little
too close
but leffen takes game two and he's
laughing he's like this man
he's not on my level chilling has
brilliant experience with the ncsc
version
good job by lefty nice charge up smash
still laughing
3-0 it looks like it's first to five
yeah
yes sir he's just waiting whoa
left it did you just really do it
firefox off stage into up here we're
done
and leffen said to me at paragon good
sir that he's going to fight both
children
how do you feel about this do you think
it's going to happen
for chilling's sake i hope this is not
his last match all i got to say is
you're going to have to delete that
youtube video i mean papa pay put in
that work it looked really great
but you're gonna have to take that off
youtube man chilling chilling
still some fight left in him he can make
this big
wait the knockdown that's enough smash
and a 5-0 right now chillin gets the
throne he is not using this color fox
anymore
and that is it what a humbling
experience leffen
wins that's right leffen dunked on chile
the final score was five nothing and
while there were some close games
shillin was never actually able to get
on the board he had been humiliated in
front of the entire smash community
and this is all he had to say you have
anything you want to say to the people
maybe basically in my head
the way that my b was formulated
was how can i get off this stage
the fastest possible the fewest number
of
letters even that i can say
to leave this stage immediately
following
chilen's destruction mango got up to say
a few words in his friend's defense
betting leffen a thousand dollars that
he could beat him in bracket
unfortunately for the home crowd leffen
destroyed a mango too
whoa if he does this he's the best
yeah if he does this man up till not
gonna oh
yes it is what of all the ways for the
set to end
and up till now leffen may not have
gotten on his flight back home with a
first-place trophy but he was eleven
hundred dollars richer thanks to chillin
and mango and he had thoroughly
humiliated some of the community's
favorite players but that's not the real
legacy of
chillin and leffen's beef in spite of
being five years old
respect your elders is sitting at nearly
1.5 million views on youtube
and in that time it's inspired countless
memes and
dozens of remixes and covers we all got
when looking at your fox not a banner
you ain't standing in your ground
when he's down even leffen has taken a
stab at it like i'll beat mango i'm the
favorite of your chokes as far as armada
goes i'll just wait until she'll host
what the hell was that for the most part
people don't even remember the money
match part of leffen and chilin's feud
the beef is long dead with leffen even
giving chillin the right to use the
default fox palette again way back in
2016.
the truth is that these two dudes don't
hate each other and
probably never did it was all just for
show it was a promo
and the entire smash community were
marks it didn't matter who won
the whole thing increased both their
profiles probably said chillin dude was
more fun to beat just because like
it created so much so many fun memes and
jokes and
the my b thing will always be remembered
i couldn't even keep a straight face you
can literally see that i'm about to like
crack up
oh god okay
yeah [ __ ] yeah but what do you have to
say
you hear that [ __ ] laughing a little
[ __ ]
obviously even people from outside smash
already know leffen's part of the
epilogue
he went on to be one of the greatest
melee players of all time
won what is likely to be the last melee
evo trophy ever
and was ranked second in the world in
2019 but chillin's side of things
isn't told as often he's become a
popular commentator
streamer and beloved elder statesman of
the smash scene
there's one thing chillin dude's known
for is being pc
yep that's all i do i'm extremely
esports
as esports as it gets baby that's me
we got some great [ __ ] matches coming
up
[Laughter]
and although he doesn't seriously
compete that often these days his love
affair
with hip hop hasn't slowed down at all
it's your boy
chillin dude absolutely killin fools
might be just a little rude heated up
like grillin food it's been a while it's
time for a new flow i'm chillin that's
too cold i'm takin a shot at you go
at the end of the day chill and did
something that most people let alone
esports competitors would be terrified
to do
he stuck his neck out there and turned
himself into a star
and even though he ended up with egg on
his face you have to respect that
esports needs more people who are
willing to jokingly beef who have big
personalities and who record diss tracks
even if they are a little cringe i
appreciate i appreciate the battle rap
because it actually hikes
up you know before the match actually
starts chilling dude is a pioneer and
that's why so many people
love respect your elders and real ones
the people who
get how important the song is know every
single word
[Applause]
so it turns out that respect your elders
is fire actually
lyrical audible gold a soul-crushing
diss track
soul-crushing diss [ __ ] it's so hard to
say
a soul-crushing diss track a
soul-crushing diss track
a soul-crushing diss track from which oh
my god